MIGUEL HERNAN: Causal
graphs are your friends.
And to show you why,
in this segment, I'm
going to describe a scientific
controversy from the late '70s.
This is a debate that involved
some of the most brilliant
clinical investigators at the time.
And by the end of this session,
when we will talk a little bit more
about graphs in the
next segments, you will
be able to resolve this
controversy by yourself
and you will be convinced that
causal graphs help us think better.
The 1970s was a fascinating decade that
will be remembered for many things,
but one of the most important things
that happened during the early '70s
is that for the first time in
human history millions of women
were receiving estrogen after menopause.
And this use of estrogen was
encouraged by doctors, by the media,
by popular books.
However, investigators were very
concerned, because in 1975 and '76,
there were some studies that found
that women receiving estrogens
had a higher risk of being diagnosed
with endometrial cancer than women
not receiving estrogens.
And the question is why?
There is one obvious answer--
possible answer -- which is
that estrogens cause cancer.
But there were two prominent
clinical investigators
from Yale, Alvin Feinstein
and Ralph Horwitz,
and they proposed another possibility.
They said that estrogens did
not have to cause cancer for us
to find this association
between estrogen use and cancer.
They said that what might
happen is that estrogens simply
lead to a diagnosis of cancers
that were already present,
but would not have been diagnosed
in the absence of estrogens.
They knew that between 20 and 60% of
cancers are silent and asymptomatic,
we only find them when we look for them.
And estrogen use causes
uterine bleeding inside women.
So they reasoned that the
bleeding was leading doctors
to diagnose preexisting silent cancers.
And as a result, estrogen users have
a higher rate of diagnosis of cancer,
even if estrogens did not
cause cancer by themselves.
So what Feinstein and Horwitz
said, in their own words is,
"If estrogens provoke the bleeding
that leads to uterine exam,
asymptomatic uterine cancer
is much more likely to be
found in women receiving estrogens
than in those who do not receive it."
And they thought that
this could fully explain
the association between estrogen
use and endometrial cancer.
They refer to this phenomenon
as ascertainment bias.
Therefore, we have two
possible explanations
for the association between
estrogen use and endometrial cancer.
One explanation is that
estrogens simply accelerate
the diagnosis of existing cancers, and
two, estrogens actually cause cancer.
Now, these two explanations
have very different implications
for clinical practice
and for public health.
The question is how can we distinguish
between these two explanations?
Which one is responsible for the
association between estrogen use
and endometrial cancer?
And this is where the
debate was initiated
and there was some discrepancies
among investigators
that we're going to discuss now.
On the one hand, the
investigators from Yale,
they proposed the following approach.
They said, well, since
estrogens make some women bleed
and therefore, more likely to be
diagnosed with preexisting cancer, when
we analyze data from
these studies, let's
restrict the data analysis
to women who bleed,
whether they are taking
estrogens or not.
If we do that, then all women in the
analysis, because they all have bled,
they all have the same likelihood
of being diagnosed with cancer
if they have an existing cancer.
And therefore, if we still find an
association between estrogen use
and cancer, it must be that
estrogens cause cancer.
But there were other equally
prominent investigators who disagreed.
People like Hershel Jick,
Ken Rothman, and Alec Walker,
from Boston University
and Harvard University,
said that restricting to women
who bleed was not the solution.
They argued that we would find an
association between estrogen and cancer
diagnosis even among
women who bleed, and even
if estrogens don't cause cancer.
As a consequence, if that
was true, then the approach
that was proposed by
the Yale investigators
would not truly distinguish between
the two possible explanations.
We would still have some
form of ascertainment bias.
And you may be wondering
how is this possible?
What the Boston investigators
said, it seems counter-intuitive.
Because if all women selected for the
analysis experienced bleeding, then
there should be no association due
to the differential ascertainment.
Well, we will return to this
question at the end of this lesson.
By that time, you'll be able to
resolve this problem by yourself.